they live in squalor but at least this
safe
a group of Pro hinge refugees have made
this shantytown in Delhi the home many
work as rag pickers and casual laborers
this is where we met Hafiz Ahmad last
year he had arrived two years ago he had
been issued refugee documentation by the
United Nations but he was struggling to
feed his five children he couldn't find
work he didn't speak Hindi and found it
hard to adapt to India but a year on
things have changed
Hafiz can navigate Delhi's chaotic roads
ever since he began driving a rented
rickshaw it brings him a regular income
I meet a lot of Indian commuters through
my work I interact more with Indians now
than with people from my own community
that has definitely helped my Hindi it's
improving and I wanted to become even
better in future like these many here
have integrated into Indian society
about 70 oranga families live in the
settlement in southeast Delhi
Hafiz Ameth has been here for the last
three years his life has certainly
gotten better but like many refugees
here Hafiz is deeply worried by reports
that the Indian government is now
considering deporting them back to
Myanmar it's a frightening thought amid
reports in the international media of a
mass exodus hundreds of thousands of
Loranger
are playing violence after an army
offensive in Myanmar's Rakhine State
Hafiz can't read and write but he keeps
up with the news on dozens of whatsapp
groups where users post graphic videos
of the unfolding crisis on the Myanmar
border Hafiz is no doubt what a
deputation in these circumstances will
mean if the Indian government forcibly
sends us back my children's future will
be ruined
everything will be over but there's no
Humanity in Myanmar towards Roo hinges
we'll all be killed if we're sent back
the feelings are shared by many of
appeases friends in the settlement
there's little else they speak off
nowadays I'm very scared my mother and
sisters still live in Myanmar some of my
relatives have been killed where would
we go
but some are clinging on to a sliver of
hope when I fled from Myanmar and came
to India I realized everyone has rights
here even animals have rights this is a
law-based country there's equality I
can't imagine the government will send
us back during this crisis it's
something this Ranger community
desperately wants to believe in